That's right. With a touch input type in particular
we can easily get multiple touch move events, inside a
single rendering frame refresh. It's pretty silly to try
to paint the screen multiple times during a single video
frame. We're just wasting work like we learned about
in the last lesson in performance. So, it's even more
important when writing touch event handler code. To not
actually draw things, inside that touch event handler. But actually,
buffer them up and paint them inside a
request animation frame handler. Now, you may have
noticed, that inside my synthesizer, I'm actually setting
classes, which cause CSS refreshers in response to touch
messages. This could be a problem, except that
setting that class happens relatively infrequently. It only happens
when you transition from one key to another.
So ,it's not causing multiple refreshes per paint cycle.
Which is what we're, really trying to avoid.